- [Instructor] We have
different statements here
that can each be expressed
as an algebraic expression,
and as you might have guessed,
I would love you to pause this video
and try to write each of these statements
as an algebraic expression
before we do it together.
All right, now let's work on it together.
So this first statement,
we have two less than x.
So my brain thinks, all
right, let me start with x,
and how am I going to
get two less than that?
Well, I'm going to subtract two.
And this is an interesting example
because you see the order that we see it
in the sentence is not the order
that we would necessarily write it
in the expression right over here.
Very important to think
about, what is going on here?
What is being described?
Now, this next statement,
y fewer than three.
Well, in my mind, I'm
going to start with three
and I'm going to be y fewer than that.
So I'm gonna start with three
and then I'm going to
be y fewer than that.
Now, these first two
statements are similar
in that you have something
less than something else
or something fewer than something else.
They just swapped the
number and the variable.
Now, this third statement,
x decreased by five.
So my mind is thinking,
what am I starting with?
I'm starting with an x and
I'm decreasing it by five.
So I can do that as minus five,
or I'm gonna take five away from it.